let's try oh i don't know how about
kevin from seattle
kevin from seattle you are next up
go ahead
yes
yeah oh oh awesome thanks so much for
taking my call um
i have a question but before i get to my
question i first want to say that
um
that your content your content creation
is proficient
having followed you for at least a year
and
keep up the good work
thank you
with that said i have been following um
um
left
left content creators for
probably a few years ever since
um kyle kolinsky said they were talking
about
2015 i think that's where i started
politics start following politics and
it it's it's come to my in my um
my awareness that
there are
in my opinion there are
problems um i've been noticing in um
these
in content creating creators if not the
in this communities of these content
creators mostly
just the insular nature of
them like like they're
there are a lot of these um problems
like for instance for instance
it's difficult it can when i'm listening
to like a content creator um
what i'm receiving or what i'm hearing
from people within that certain
community like say like say particular
talk for example or i'll say young turks
i'm getting
the i'm getting just the opinions from
from say the content creators but but
nothing beyond that and it becomes a
little bit difficult to
if when there are outside opinions um
for people within within a community to
like accept
outside opinions
um like
we can go over some some examples but i
think that
because of my experience um i decided to
like
change it up not and i decided to like
read the news instead of following
content creators and since then
um i think my awareness in politics
and current events has expanded and it's
personally um
it personally has benefited me um
that's my question
um i know in
your show you talk about um
media literacy
um i was learning like for the purposes
of not only media literacy but
responsible content consumption if it's
a good idea to like
um
do you think do you think uh cause um
consumers should reduce the dependency
of um
content of
political opinions for or these online
content creators um do you think they
should reduce dependency on that instead
for instance instead of that say they
should just read the news
kevin thank you for the question um i uh
i have said many times before there's
sort of a media consumption pyramid that
i think makes sense i think the base of
the pyramid is really reading
non-fiction books history economics
political philosophy etc that should be
the base of the pyramid
next after that it goes to reading
reports in newspapers and periodicals
and then the top of the pyramid would be
consuming content like mine or that of
others i think that makes for the most
well-rounded media diet where you're
coming into opinion programming like my
show
with a base
of understanding history philosophy
uh political science etc then you are
reading ideally as close as there is to
to just reporting about what's going on
and then you fill that in with with
shows like mine i think that's the
healthiest media diet
it's like like food pyramid exactly
exactly kevin i've got a ton of people
waiting so i'm gonna let you go i
appreciate that we were able to get to
the question thank you very much
if you ever feel like you just don't
have enough time to read all the books
you want to read you have to check out
one of my favorite apps called blinkist
blinkist takes thousands of popular
nonfiction books and distills each one
down into an e-book or audiobook that
you can get through in just 15 minutes
where you're getting all the key
takeaways from the book just imagine how
you'll be able to expand your horizons
and knowledge by being able to soak up
all of the important insights from 10
different books
in an afternoon obviously it's perfect
for exposing yourself to a new book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for or you
can use it to revisit a book you've
already read or use it to preview a book
before you buy the full version and read
it i recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great stephen
hawking this is a book that i have been
aware of for so long and other things
got in the way and it was fantastic to
check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription is only
about eight bucks a month and you get
the entire library but you can try it
totally free and get twenty five percent
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com slash pacman i've put the
link right underneath this video